[Music]
what's up guys how are you guys doing
how you guys holding up are you guys
enjoying your time at home wait are you
talking to us or to them I would we
don't matter talking to them first okay
all right you'll stay wet and then I'm
gonna look at you guys like how are you
guys continue they can't talk back yes
leave a comment because comment back
yeah YouTube but I want to post more
videos for them honestly like when
they're sitting at home I feel like we
got to do our part here and keep them
like we give we got to be that little
blanket of just happiness well I'm doing
live with Steve so you come over to mine
maybe hopefully next year I might post
something yesterday different case oh
well I mean like since we've all been in
quarantine like what do you guys been up
to what's what's poppin well I think the
first week you do all the things that
everyone else does your watch shows you
jackoff you watch porn you do that over
and over you cook food you eat whatever
and then you get to the point of what is
the meaning of life because all the
things that I wanted to do for this year
just completely changed yeah my life
sorry yeah everything stopped like I
wanted to travel a lot this year and
then you know then Rona happened so that
was my goal is to do a lot of that get
back into changing things up in JK and
we got things moving and then Rona
happened yeah I don't know how about you
guys yeah for for me it was like what
Jake hey at least it was like trying to
like push danger boys and like you know
the whole like moviemaking stuff and
like you know and I felt like we were
gaining traction for once you know we're
like we've got some completed scripts we
got to complete a project that we're
trying to I push and then we have this
brand-new idea that we're trying to
write as well yeah and then like this
thing happens and it just kind of
dampens the whole mood of the the the
meetings that were ever so trying to
write via Skype and all that but like
you said it's just not the student
everything is shut down huh they stopped
filming Batman like it's crazy Holly
what's done like
six shows lined up for people to watch
danger boys right
and it just scrub done that's true I
remember you guys were gonna have one at
Cal State Long Beach right and then I
think we're all gonna go yeah we're all
gonna go and then I just remembered like
um I forgot whoever made the legal
announcements like oh we gotta be in
quarantine by this day and I was like oh
[ __ ] how are you guys still gonna do the
show and then turns out you guys kept oh
yeah same for us like I we we went to
like a business seminar and like we were
like ramping up all our personal
businesses and like barbell and our own
brands and stuff and we were gaining
traction and then it happens and it's
like [ __ ] everything kind of just fell
and it stopped like the traveling
stopped I was gonna travel a lot this
year and that is complete I don't even
know if I want to travel anymore
kind of scary even if it's okay to
travel oh yeah I still want to travel I
feel like I've been just because I still
got like work luckily I stopped like
edit video shoot videos and stuff for
like in a safe way but besides that I
feel like I'm trying to stay positive
and not use this time to do other things
that I typically wouldn't have time for
like trying to push business and stuff
is kind of hard but I you still can
start the things that were like more
passion projects that I'm trying to like
focus my time on what are you doing -
like pivot and like do guys something
different since I'm home or I could cook
and do everything I've been fixing my
diet I've been like really good about
that I've been like really good about
training and like making sure that I'm
you're actually more productive now even
though I feel like I was doing a good
amount I realized with like little
things of going here going there Kiki
with people or like in the gym a little
bit longer it takes up so much time that
how much free time I actually have so
now I'm trying to like okay I have this
much free time
don't let this time of just being bored
go to waste yeah and not come out of
this with something because I'm like if
we're gonna be here with this why not
come out of it like like if I come out
around the script and I can go when
Hollywood starts back up that might put
me an advantage compared to other people
oh sure they're just like I wanted more
even from before because now I hear that
jacked off and just it all that well I'm
still doing all that
even more like make time for that huh
yeah definitely yeah you have to a lot
of time take off more now yeah I would
skip off wait where do you stay oh okay
oh let's skip out on jacking off like
pre quarantine I'll be like I got to
wake up in five hours how long does it
take you to check off well I mean like
it's just the whole thing you know like
every minute counts maybe it's like
romance something off you're not
sleeping
yeah that's true when you're getting one
the other ones getting away I don't know
if you guys can't relate but have you
ever you know you watch the show on
Netflix or something right and you go
I'm just gonna watch one before I go to
sleep
oh yeah you go another one another one
no I live this part that doesn't happen
well yeah but maybe if you experience it
by yourself you could go on a marathon
right yeah but then I think that's kind
of what happens where I'm like I'm gonna
do a quickie tonight and then I [ __ ]
purposely don't try to come and before I
knew it I'm like [ __ ] I thought I was
gonna sleep early purposely don't try to
come edges edging yeah it's fun it's
[ __ ] great because if you edge well I
don't know it's I don't know if it's the
same for the girl but if you edge you
experience more explosive orgasms I
think like when you just come
immediately it's never as satisfying as
like when you go about the bus and then
you all wait let me watch another video
cuz it's like the first I would say 70%
is just getting there yeah last 30 or 20
is the best plan part then the last time
there's like the really good part but
that's quick yes you want to stay within
the last like 72 minutes exactly too
much man we're doing math every time
it's like this it's like okay let me
show you guys you want to ride this you
want to get here and you want to ride
this yeah cuz you don't want to go go to
sleep that would be a boring roller
coaster foods just one Western you do
multiple and then dilute it yeah
you don't want the the thing that just
launches you up and makes you go down
and then you get off the lift right you
want the whole [ __ ] Lu are you guys
trying to get Vantage of this quarantine
at all I wish I could but I have a
toddler so none that no work gets done
on my own
zero at all cuz it's just like Mummy
Mummy Mummy Mummy Mummy
yeah but it's not different from your
regular life because how you have him
were you yummy you kind of like chilled
out a JK and everything else and you
just been home more so that was cool
because I didn't have that pressure
right I don't have stress of like I need
to take care of this I should be having
at my hands in this I should understand
this that this deadlines not happening
when I was completely out of everything
it was just focus on him but now because
we did the business thing I'm talking
more [ __ ] yeah I'm coming back into the
company so I'm trying to catch up to
speed I'm trying to figure out what's
going on it stops but I'm still kind of
in it so I'm still like okay are we
meeting deadlines how are we gonna prove
it to here how are we gonna make money
here oh [ __ ] this factory whatever but
I'm like oh [ __ ] Tigers got eat oh [ __ ]
I can eat alright and your mom's not
here she's not there so I'm like
completely like I don't know I don't
know I'm getting on up fault
I'm gonna come up fault yeah I'm like
how the [ __ ] did I get more busier I
mean I know I'm talking about jacking
off and savoring the moments of edging a
big part of it is the cooking and
cleaning the home and doing my but I'm
like I did that I didn't know I didn't
do that I didn't cook and clean oh yeah
I'm we just did laundry when I could
you're looking right into my eyes but it
was that I wasn't here we made eye
contact but it was not I'm not there all
these stories now from parents who are
like having to deal with this extra
stress of their kids having to learn
from home yeah oh yeah and like you're
now both a parent and a teacher for them
while they're home and you're holding
down your job still yeah for people who
work at home yeah it's crazy I see
parents
that are like they're hosting their
meetings and [ __ ] are there zoom calls
like in the [ __ ] closet and then the
baby comes out in the [ __ ] start
today yeah you just closed and [ __ ] hey
no they'll lock it but you can hear the
make mom dead and you're just like what
do we still get dressed up like nice
only in the top half like the parents to
the top only podcast is just this up
doesn't get up and go [ __ ] get in
water and if she's hanging out you know
this viral video that came out recently
it was like a business meeting of like
15 people and one guy didn't know they
had his camera on still and he was nude
he was just walking around eating an
apple who was doing it from home she has
that ain't she has it angles she's in
the kitchen and you can see the hallway
and her dad comes out with his big ol
belly she's like no dad no there's one
where the girl was taking a class and so
like what I think the teacher was
talking and then she takes a laptop and
you just hear start walking right and
then she goes to the bathroom sets it
down and he's here just pull down her
pants I was like y'all you and this
she's like looks like camera shuts it
off and then you just see her like
picture disappear the P sound yeah those
stories of like the fuck-ups that
happened during like zoom like business
calls of [ __ ] I saw this one where it
was like a guy that was reporting on
news and he was on this couch he had a
suit on with just his underwear right
and he's like reporting and it was like
his son that was showing the live TV
footage any panned out that he showed
his back yeah so that's great
and is that gonna do [ __ ] can you just
smiling you can see smiling bullet
screen I love it kids are so nice are
you guys getting used to being in
quarantine or is it I [ __ ] love it
dude I feel like regular life now it
does it feel like because I feel like
I'm used to aware it feels like this is
like how life is now yeah I like what
life used to be like going out and
seeing friends is like home so much
before yeah exactly I'm the same too
like I don't feel like it was that much
of a difference for me because maybe we
all have the luxury of working from home
we don't need to go to a nine-to-five
in an office or deal with people with
what we do we are just more nervous yeah
we just kind of craft your own videos or
whatever we upload and we're kind of
done for the rest of the day I'm never
home you never home so I recently
discovered my garage there's so much
space in here and you know it's been
raining and I've been setting up a gym
I'm all like [ __ ] I have so much space
that I'm not utilizing and then I
brought in a little table from my other
office like I'm dressing up my rooms
like and I'm really enjoying my space
that I never did before that's it oh
yeah my kitchen yeah but I'm just there
to sleep what's your address
yeah yeah I feel like not much has
changed for me the only nice changes
just my commute time because it'll take
me about an hour to get to work no no no
I like it now I don't have to get to
work and so now I don't need to do that
I could just like wake up ten minutes
before I'm eating and be like oh great I
just pop them in the laptop hey what's
up guys hey
no I'm great okay but I mean yeah
nothing much has changed and I don't
think any of my plans have come to a
halt my stress and anxiety and all that
[ __ ] has left you know why I realized
that our lifestyle in LA the driving the
meetings the schedule that's been
[ __ ] with me and I didn't know that
because it was every day oh [ __ ] I gotta
get there I gotta go here I got to
finish this whatever right now I just
finish things like doing the time that I
want so like I'm cooking
last night I was cooking till midnight
dude after Ike we got home
[ __ ] dude I made steak and eggs I made
ceviche or I'm planning I have to plan
ahead cuz because of the the I'm gonna
be busy so sometimes I'll make a big
batch of food and yeah I I was spending
three hours just cooking did you perfect
your creping all that stuff oh I didn't
make any fun yet but I have chicken pho
ready to go
so I've chicken fart ready to go I have
steak and eggs that I ate last night I I
made two pounds of ceviche shrimp it's
like two [ __ ] buckets of it I got a
ton of vegetables man it's gonna be
really good you didn't make anything
with your lemons I didn't hear any
lemons in this ceviche beaches all in it
is a lot of lemon I like lime and your
father yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]